[Music]
I got
cancelled my son has cried every single
day for 3 years and it's crazy because
over the last 3 years I've cried every
single day for different reasons you
know he's like I'm hungry I'm like I
want my [__] career back
[__] doing all this therapy she said
to me well that's no surprise you're a
comedian I said what do you mean I know
you think you like to do stand up
because you like to make people laugh
when people laugh that means that they
accept you and you need that and that's
when I was like you're a [__]
[__] I'm just a guy and I'm just trying
to do better okay they don't want you to
change that's the truth I got back on
stage and people were just like what the
are you but I [__] typed so [__]
hard